je m'appelle laurence mandon j'ai 47ans
et je suis agricultrice et j'habite
effectivement dans le canton numéro 24
où j'ai été élu donc sur la commune du
tampon un des deux cantons de la commune
du tampon
dans le canton numéro 24 c'est le canton
à des deux cantons de la commune du
tampon qui va depuis le dassier qui
montent jusque dans les eaux au niveau
du bourg murat donc effectivement un
grand territoire qui va depuis
l'altitude 600 mètres jusqu'à plus de
2000 mètres d'altitude
je suis très attaché à ce canton puisque
effectivement moi je suis originaire
donc de trois marins des quartiers de ce
canton et en plus je travaille en tant
qu'agricultrice sur ce canton au niveau
de la plaine des cafres où je fais de
l'élevage donc en tant qu'agricultrice
ie6 attaché à ce canton
au cours de cette mandature mois je
souhaiterais vraiment continuer à
travailler dans l'intérêt de
l'agriculture mais surtout je dirais
plus des agriculteurs puisque ce sont
des collègues de la profession je pense
qu'au niveau de ce canton sur la commune
du tampon que où l'agriculture est très
présente donc il y à un réel besoin de
soutenir les agriculteurs de cette de ce
canton et de cette commune je
souhaiterais bien sûr continuer les
offres sociales puisque on connaît le
contexte social qui est très tendu et
très difficile et bien sûr va continuer
à travailler pour soutenir les familles
les plus démunies dans leur intérêt pour
qu'il y ait vraiment cette cohésion de
bien vivre ensemble sur ce canton 24 et
au tampon
j'ai choisi d'être conseillère
départementale c'est effectivement en
tant qu'agricultrice l'agriculture est
une des compétences du département donc
moi je suis très attaché à continuer à
soutenir l'agriculture et bien sûr comme
je suis quelqu'un qui suit qui est élu
de proximité
moi même qui suis élu des milieux
associatifs donc effectivement la
proximité du département c'est quelque
chose qui me tient à coeur être en
contact de la population et pouvoir les
aider à continuer à bien vivre je dirais
sur sur la commune